so that in Turkey's president has warned
Damascus against further provocations in
Syria's last rebel-held territory Recep
Tayyip Erdogan says he will strike
against government forces anywhere if
they target Turkish troops in in Lib
province
he's also demanding Syrian forces be
pushed back beyond Turkish observation
post by the end of February these
attacks are directly targeting our
soldiers and directly targeting Turkey
there is no more time for talk we have
to look at the realities on the field
and act by the end of February the
regime must be pushed behind our
observation points whatever is needed on
the ground or in the air we are not
going to have any hesitation and we are
going to act on it well Syrian
government forces have killed 15 Turkish
soldiers in aid live in recent days and
much of the fighting in the past week
has focused on the m5 highway which is a
main trade route that linked Damascus
with a leopard government forces are now
fully in control of that crucial highway
while the fighting has triggered a
humanitarian crisis has displaced nearly
700,000 people Russia is blaming the
escalation on Turkey saying the presence
of their troops in it live is making the
situation worse
very chilly news NECA krodha say the
reasons for the current deterioration
that we are witnessing in Eid Lib is
Turkey's continued failure to fulfill
its obligation under the search in
memorandum and anchors transfer of units
of the so-called moderate armed
opposition to northeastern Syria well
let's hear now from our reporter cm
Koziol who's in the town of Bab al-hawa
in Syria and she explains the positions
held by both Syrian and Turkish forces
in the area the Syrian government is
first bombarding the areas and pushing
the civilians out of the areas and then
entering those villages and it seems
they are eager to continue from south to
the north and take over a full control
inside adlib in the middle of the
escalation zone despite a multilateral
agreement that it should be a deconflict
zone it should be at the arms area and
the civilians my shall be able to freely
move here so given the situation given
them a rapid advance by the Syrian
government and
very harsh weather conditions there is a
humanitarian crisis on the ground which
has been there actually for many years
there are at least four million people
right behind Turkish borders an ad lib
and at least 1 million are by the border
in Atma area and there is in there there
is not enough space left for any more
civilians and as a Syrian government
offensives continue there are more and
more people to space every every day and
despite all these well this is a proxy
war the military experts say and both
the Syrian government and the Turkish
government are devoted to continue their
reinforcements for their military bases
of course still it is unknown whether
this is going to be a direct war a bilat
war between Ankara and damascus or will
they end up with a diplomatic solution
let's take this on let's speak to our
senior political analyst my own Bashara
joins us now from London tomorrow in
Russia pointing a finger firmly at
Turkey Derwin is defiant where is this
heading it sounded to me like that we
are approaching a moment of truth
because on the one hand the Syrian
regime is advancing in Italy and even in
the areas of Aleppo with a huge terrible
human cost to Syrians as your report
said several hundred almost 700,000 new
refugees in the last 10 weeks and
clearly the Turks being hurt humiliated
but also their soldiers killed lashing
out and the president of Turkey talking
to Parliament about a national emergency
of sort and basically issuing ultimatum
to the Syrian regime means either the
Syrian regime is gonna have to back out
or turkey is gonna have to respond
either way there are we are in the midst
of paralysis and to be honest there are
far more questions about what's going on
and the players in Syria than there are
answers at this point would the Syrian
regime back out and how does Russia fit
into all of this
well that takes me back to your original
question I mean is is the Syrian regime
playing games with with Moscow and
Ankara or is Russia playing games with
Syria and Turkey if if the puppet master
is Putin and they're the one that's
pushing the regime from behind the scene
then clearly Moscow is interested in in
the end the regime continuing his
aggressive or its aggressive attacks on
the north regardless of the human cost
and regardless of Turkey's humiliation
that could take us into a whole new
ballgame because turkey is not about to
let the Syrian regime take control of
all over northern Syria at a huge human
cost because there is also the question
of millions of refugees that have
already fled to Turkey and several
hundred thousand might also be crossing
borders unless turkey takes charge of
that of that of that part but that
actually takes me to another point Nick
quickly which is something that I give
on the question of eaglet because it
cannot continue to be the bleeding wound
of Syria when everyone knows that some
arrangement has to take place and that
this cannot just continue like an open
wound open-ended lessly in the end of
the day Ankara and Moscow have to reach
an agreement about who's acting in an ad
lib and whether turkey should at the end
of the day take over the province
disarmed it in order for the Syrians to
be at last living in some sort of safety
so if you look at the players every
Syria itself turkey Russia and then
there is the United States what about
them well clearly the Unites States as
we all know has detached itself with
president from pulling its troops out
but now we we see a report we hear
reports about the special envoy James
Jeffery meeting with the Turks and
voicing American support to Turkey
that's written you will give it will
give the Turkish president is some
leverage if you were with Russia
because in the end of the day America's
role is it remains important even if
there isn't that many forces there we
also know of a skirmish between the
American forces and the right and the
Syrian regime that means Americans are
really interested in supporting the
Turks Europeans on the other hand I mean
I don't want to use words like pathetic
but certainly their response has been so
evasive and so weak when Europe is far
more affected by what goes on in Syria
than the United States Europe has more
leverage is more proximate and should be
not only reacting to what Moscow and
Ankara are doing but should be proactive
because it continues to complain about
the issue of refugees of instability on
its borders but it's not doing enough
neither for the humanitarian catastrophe
called Syria nor for the strategic
calculus that is taking place on the
ground today or tomorrow and thanks very
much indeed mom Bashar the tough news
from London